Film Courage: How do you get a movie
made? Can you explain the exact process?
Robert Rippberger, Filmmaker: If only there was
a process there's so many different ways to get
a movie made and that's partly the the tricky part
is where to start and what what method to go about
it but fundamentally it requires resources it
requires money enlisting people on your vision and
having a very clear vision of what you want to do
and how you want that to interact with the world
so I would say it it obviously it starts
with a good story you then have to have
resources or people contributing resources
to that but it is it's certainly not easy
and so it it takes a lot of determination and
gusto to keep it moving so it sounds like each
project that you've worked on because you have
quite a few under your belt or that you've been
a part of is different each time yeah every every
project that comes together is is a bit different
and usually it takes a tremendous amount of
I guess me believing in myself that we can
pull something off even when it looks
like the odds are stacked against us
there's been projects where we were a week away
from filming and we didn't have all the money
to finish filming and it was just we'll get there
we'll figure it out and then we were able to close
the financing last week of filming at least for me
there's always a strong sense in which like things
always seem to work themselves out and so I think
that's in turn sort of led to a lot of confidence
and also that I put myself around other
people who I can depend on and rely on and
yeah and sometimes take these risks but we
sort of say okay we'll figure it out as we go
so if you were to help another filmmaker
that has never made a film and let's
suppose they want to get an investor do
you have the script first or do you have
someone that you think can get you to that
investor and you have just an idea and you
certainly in going to an investor have to have all
of your sort of ducks in a row you need to have
a script you need to have a lookbook you need to
have a budget as it's sort of been outlined for me
you need to show them that you have a good idea
and that you have the people to be able to pull
it off and so it's those key things and also
what I found too is momentum behind you you
have to have momentum behind you because it's
always very easy for that investor to say I
love it I want to put money into it but let
me know when you're a little further along
and so you need to give a clear sense
that well this is going right we're we're
a month away from filming or we're this
is right around the corner and you need
to also mean it right it's not it's not just
a sort of smoke and mirror it's like if that
investor goes away you need to also know that
you are filming definitely don't over oversell
but it's that type of environment that
brings people in and gets people excited
and certainly in believing in yourself others
are also going to believe in in you too and so
a lookbook would be used even for a documentary
certainly I mean people love visuals and they
what you're trying to do is you're trying to
sell something to somebody that doesn't exist
right if I said hey I've got this house do
you want to buy it I've got these blueprints
it's not going to be as effective as if I say
well now you can walk through this whole CAD
design of the house itself right you can even
put on this VR headset and sort of walk into
the home and take a look right then it's real
then it's real and that's always the hardest
thing is how to and this is why people do
sort of like what they call rip-o-matics
where they kind of re-cut other films to
kind of give a sense of the look and style
because it's you're trying to make something
real now that people can put their money into
that gives a whole 3D sort of fully immersive
view of of what it is to watch that film
ultimately in theaters how often are you hired
as a director and how often are you working as
a director on one of your own projects as often
as possible I'm directing projects of my own
and then from time to time I am also hired on
other projects it is I say no to a lot more
that I'm asked to direct but it does happen and
certainly getting into larger and larger films
and certainly open to the idea but I've just
found that the stories that I kind of cultivate
whether it's buying a script or whether it's
writing something my own or hiring a writer to do
that generally in putting out all that time I can
increase the odds greatly that film will actually
get made where whereas sometimes projects that
come in they are moving and then things fall
apart and then they come back again and so
I think largely it's a function of of time
and also just how far and how ready that
project is to go before I step into to direct it
when you see buying a script are you actively
looking for ones on let's say a website that
has scripts for sale or are people presenting them
to you so people will contact me from time to time
we generally don't accept unsolicited materials
there's a couple companies around town that I've
asked to just sort of pass me projects if
they really believe in them and then I have
a sort of network of writers that I that
I know that all hire on on various things
we don't option projects which is a bit
different than other companies because
our view is that if we're going to make
the film we're going to make the film so
we're not kind of wasting time on on optioning
it so we just just outright by it and
yeah but it's always a very fluid project process
and for now we kind of have the next two projects
set out and kind of made our calendar for the rest
of 2022. but yeah it's never it's never precise
but we we always are looking for for projects that
really resonate and that we feel can can connect
with audiences do you think there's an energy
to working on multiple projects at one time
certainly having lots of irons in the fire
is I feel a necessity for working in film
sometimes things just take longer after
availability and things need to be moved
around and so to go back and say okay well
this one we're gonna bump up on the priority
list as a result can be really really helpful and
there's certainly a strong sense of convergence
of working with different actors or different
distributors or different sales companies that
then kind of provide the infrastructure for
more films to come down a similar path and
so certainly as as many irons in the fire
as possible without compromising quality
and yeah without compromising the core
things of what it is to make a good movie
do you have like a different spreadsheet for
each project like how do you delineate each one
I tend to just kind of keep it all in my head
so we I keep it a to-do list basically weekly
of sort of full double page of all the things
that need to happen on a specific project and
then when I do go into direct I basically pass all
of the tasks off on other projects off to my other
producers or other coordinators and the reason
is is directing I feel needs to be completely all
in that everything around is quiet that you're
just there being present to all the department
heads to the actors and to that story and that
world itself how do you raise money for a movie
the way to raise money for a film is
really to start with the people that
if you're doing an independent film
there's there's crowdfunding platforms
or it's to package the film and really put
a director on board to put actors on board
to put other key producers on board and then to
take it to a studio to take it to a production
company or to take it to independent film
financiers there's so many different ways
and scales and manners to pull together a film
depending on the genre and the budget level
but what I always always do and I think
this is why I've I've been able to turn
around so many films is I sort of put what's
the best case scenario the sometimes millions
of dollars that it would take to pull a
project off and then what's the scenario
where we absolutely bare minimum we're able
to pull this off while still having really
good production production value and so we
create this kind of accordion between the two
and oftentimes we may say okay well here's what
the number is but we still don't have it how can
we start how can we at least sort of move things
further down the line build sets and hire people
and get things get things going so that we
show that this is happening this is the vision
and then bring in investors as as we go
can you talk about how you've done that
with your last three films which I believe
are all documentaries in one narrative or no
yeah so for my last couple films the way we've
really leaned into making the movie first and
keeping that as a priority and then Finance is
coming later is first on a project that I'm doing
with the writer of Ratatouille called
the inventor it's a stop-motion film
that is just very very time consuming to do so
we actually launched first with a Kickstarter and
then used some of that money to get the the
studio up and running and we build sets and we
built puppets and costumes and simultaneously
we raised private equity from other folks and
that funded the studio for an entire year and we
haven't announced it yet but we've got a pretty
two pretty big distribution deals that are that
are about to land and that's because we we showed
this is we believe in ourselves we believe in this
film we had top talents attached to it and we took
it to can most recently and did a number of deals
there and are just about to announce our next one
but that was just like leaning into it right
like and constantly questions were how do we
keep the studio open how do we keep everybody
paid and we just kept figuring it out month by
month and getting a little bit further do
we need to put things on pause do we need
to spread out the work over a longer period
of time and ultimately everything just kept
falling into place every single month
but it was a very much a leap of faith
and I I have this I have the saying of of any film
I'm working on there's always there's a moment
where it says like there's always a test there's
always something that happens that sort of this
this voice from the world saying do you really
do you really want this do you really want to
make this film okay show me and so that's that's
those those sort of major leaps of faith that
you'll jump with your team that you have something
really special and ultimately you'll land but it's
certainly a lot of risk and I wouldn't recommend
it for everybody did you get the top name Talent
attached after the crowdfunding we had them
attached before we had them attached before we um
yeah we had shot a teaser for the film to sort of
give people an idea of the look we just literally
at each step of the way we're like how can we
drive this forward now and just time and time
again and then how can we find other partners
that can help there's a quote when you begin
tact you discover your hidden allies and so
it's so important to act to get out there and
to engage with people and find those allies who
who believe in your your vision as much as you do
and then to what you said earlier that there's
there will be a point where the universe will
say are you sure you really want this and do you
want this and maybe you need to show me and that
to really yeah I think I'm sure every project
has at least one or two of those moments yeah
and then the other two that you financed or
had financed yeah so the other the other two
projects where we did something similar was again
where we sort of set off not having all the funds
and raised it sometimes in the final weeks of
filming and but yeah I mean always it was it was
and it this isn't like insane risk like we we
always had a and we're never asking any of the
people that work for us to take any risk
whatsoever but it essentially was well we
either raise the money or we put it on a bunch
of credit cards and we didn't have to do that
but yeah it did really take that and I think it's
so hard to make independent film these days I mean
especially adding in kovid that you just have to
be super hungry and in my case things have worked
out but it certainly hasn't been from a lack of
trying right and then one of your documentaries
you had iced tea involved yeah and so did did he
approach you with a film or you had already been
working on it so we did a film called Public Enemy
Number one that looked at drug use in America
and we also knew that we wanted to get the
word out there and specifically about how
this was locking up minorities left and right
and this is obviously such a terrible Legacy
of of the drug war and so we reached out to
ice tease people and showed him the project
and he came on and did an interview for us and
also became an executive producer of the film
and I've been very fortunate that other of my
projects we've had really fantastic and generous
high profile individuals come on board and say
this is something that we see is as important
whether it was seven days in in
Syria with Angelina Jolie or our
most recent project how to build
a truth Engine with George Clooney
that really helped help to get out into the
world and that of course helps with Distributors
and builds momentum so the way that I found
to bring on executive producers is first
find out people that really are sympathetic
to that particular cause people that
ultimately you want to create a win-win and
people aren't going to just out of out of pity
or or out of one reason or another say say yes to
a project like it needs to be organic it needs to
be core values and that's what it is about Finding
fellow fellow allies and so yeah we just sort of
ask around and call their reps and put a teaser
in front of them and if it's an immediate no so
be it but we just uh really yeah really show
that just with their involvement projects can
can really take flight and sometimes people are
willing to help and it's phenomenal when they do
and then we're also very very respectful of
their time and of them lending their name and
it's a it very much is about mutual trust and so
you need to be in a place to be able to gain that
or establish that in in any relationship
and working with a a high pro profile EP
and so with seven days in Syria it was a
finished film and then you showed it to
Angelina Jolie exactly exactly okay and then
but with the movie about you said Public Enemy
the most recent oh yeah Public Enemy Number One
also is finished it was finished oh okay and
then you got Ice-T to do the interview exactly
and we cut it into the film oh interesting okay
and then with this latest film if you're
yeah with how to build the truth engine
we have a sort of sample edit of the project and
so that's something we've been taking out and
showing to different people and that's really what
what was sort of the tease of of saying okay this
isn't just words on a page I can see the quality
of the filmmaking I can see the characters you're
following and in New York Times and others
that yeah there's no question mark about
what the vision and what the impact is here and
finding people that are ready to jump onto that.